Speaker 1: Let's talk a little bit about another
hypocrisy, which is that on Fox News, they
have had all of these different news anchors,
Tucker Carlson, Laura Ingraham and all of
these.
Are you you know, the you know, the crew bemoaning
and denouncing Joe Biden's vaccine requirements
for big businesses as tyrannical, as authoritarian,
as illegal, as unconstitutional, despite not
being any of those things, when Fox News has
had an actual stricter policy on masking,
on testing and on vaccines, which the White
House is now praising, this is actually unbelievable.
The White House is now praising Fox for having
a stricter version of Biden's vaccine or test
mandate despite bashing the policy on ER.
The White House praised one of its top media
critics, Fox News, for announcing an even
stricter vaccine or test mandate than the
administration's new federal policy for employers.
Fox announced Tuesday it will soon roll out
daily covid testing for unvaccinated employees.
Remember, Biden's proposal was vaccinated
or weekly testing.
Fox is going to do vaccinated or daily testing
if you've not revealed your vaccination status
to the company.
They've asked employees to submit vaccination
status and revealed 90 percent of its employees
confirmed they had been immunized against
the virus.
Think about that.
If the country.
Was as vaccinated as Fox News employees, things
would be going way better right now, Denmark,
which is 75 percent vaccinated, which is still
almost 50 percent greater than us.
Denmark is essentially wide open with declining
cases.
Fox is 90 percent vaccinated.
If the country was vaccinated, as Fox News,
which on air criticizes vaccine requirements,
we would be in a really good position right
now.
As the article says, last week, Biden announced
all employers with more than 100 employees
must mandate vaccines or weekly testing.
Fox previously required certain essential
employees to undergo regular testing.
The White House urged Fox to inform its audience
about the effectiveness of such policies.
White House spokesperson said Tuesday.
Today's news from FOX follows a trend we're
seeing across the country.
Vaccination and testing requirements work.
We're glad they've stepped up to protect their
workforce and strengthen the economy.
We encourage them to convey to their audience
that these types of practices will protect
their employees, communities and the economy.
This is in addition to Fox's policy that only
vaccinated employees can remove masks.
In some settings, all employees must be masked
in confined indoor settings.
Think about that.
Biden rolls out a policy which is you have
100 employees you've got to vaccinate or you've
got to test weekly.
No mandated masking for the unvaccinated foxes
on air.
Talent goes on and says this is tyrannical.
This is not freedom.
This is un-American.
This must be stopped.
This could be against the law.
And yet behind the scenes, Fox News has the
same vaccinator test requirement, except that
FOX it's not a weekly test.
It's a daily test if you're unvaccinated.
And in addition to that, in some settings,
if you're unvaccinated, you have to keep wearing
a mask.
It is much stricter at Fox News than what
Fox's own on air talent decries as tyrannical
government oppression as outlined by Joe Biden
in his proposal.
So why hasn't Tucker Carlson resigned to protest
these dystopian policies?
Meanwhile, he's on air saying, hey, you know
what, we've got to we've got to investigate.
We've got to fly to Trinidad to interview
Nicki Minaj, cousin's friend, whose testicles
swelled after getting the evil vaccine.
And yet he's part of a company with a stricter
requirement than what Joe Biden has laid out.
And you know, the reason why it's all disingenuous
garbage.
Tucker makes a ton of money at Fox News.
It's really that simple.
But he makes the money at Fox off of an audience
whose education and finances are different
than his.
The messaging on his show isn't for people
like him, for people in his tax bracket with
the amount of sort of market power that he
has as a well paid and and of highly rated
Fox News host.
It's for people who make a lot less money
and have a lot less market power in dealing
with their employers who actually are at much
greater risk if they show up and they say
what you guys are doing is tyrannical, Tucker
told me on Fox News.
So it's all a setup for Tucker's audience
to just blame the left blamed the left for
all of it.
And you don't you know, all of the bad things
that are happening are because of Democrats,
and we should oppose all of it, even though
Tucker himself is implicitly accepting it
by continuing to work at Fox News under a
stricter mandate than that which Joe Biden
proposed last week.
So it's pathetic and we will keep calling
it out.
But at the end of the day, if people don't
realize that this is all a ruse, they are
going to keep getting bamboozled by it and
saying no.
Tucker told me that this is tyrannical.
Tucker told me that this is bad.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.